[Music]
yesterday I was talking about the
greatness of brent mussberger that he
can go into any town remote town in
America and I mentioned Ames Iowa on a
Tuesday night and he can make it a
bigger event that's the greatness of
brent mussberger it appeared to be a
slight to those in Ames Iowa Aaron young
then wrote an article front-page article
the Des Moines Register where I am
calling out Ames Iowa how big a story
was this Aaron I mean honestly I think
the whole state of Iowa is listening
right now so when someone when my
colleagues said those still ain't that a
kick so now had put it on their social
media feed he said you know this is
something you probably do and he goes
you know it probably isn't the biggest
audience grabber in the world but you
know here we are today so you know
definitely loyalty is coming from ames
and Iowans everywhere well you found out
that I'm clickbait Aaron is what you
found out when I say something about
Ames Iowa the hotcake is what it is is
there a question you have for me about
this and they follow up article that I'm
sure will run in the Des Moines Register
yeah I mean have you ever visited Iowa
and you guys are sound like you're going
to be making a trip to Iowa what are
some of the things that you would like
to do well that's a double question
right there Aaron so you can only ask
one question here alright so what do you
think of an zila I'm only here to honor
qualcomm is what I'm what I'm doing here
okay now what I have not been to ames
but we're looking forward to maybe doing
a drive-by with the dentist and we're
not sure when we could do it but we'd
like to come in on a friday and maybe
stay for a game on saturday yeah i
definitely think i'm surprised no one
has yet to say the Iowa State Fair it's
August ten to the twentieth i believe
and it's you know one of the most
nationally known state fairs a ton of
good acts that are set up right now at
the grandstand even one of the groups I
love the 90s I got vanilla ice salt and
Pepa coolio so you guys want to come
down in August that's definitely not
that's of interest okay yeah we've
gotten a lot of uh you know welcoming
tweets things that we could do there's a
bacon festival i think the brightest
things iowa against iowa state is a game
that we could say so you know we're
ready to come in to two aims I didn't
know that there's friction between Des
Moines and ames though Aaron yeah I
think it's I mean I heard one the
collars earlier saying that's a city and
we're 35 miles away five I I mean I
don't have any friction I'm i come from
Urbandale which is a suburb Des Moines
so but yeah I mean there's always
friction in it everywhere it's not it's
not necessarily Ames vs iowa city
friction but there's frictional around
is there going to be a parade if i come
to town air and I guess who's the bigger
question I mean there could be a very
well could be okay I would you want
there to be a parade huh yeah i think so
i think it'd be kind of nice you know a
couple of floats you know Fred Fred
Hoiberg is going to lose his title as
the mayor and I'd be more than happy to
take that over and but a nice little
parade maybe a couple of floats would be
nice and cheerleaders and uh now maybe
Cael Sanderson could come out Dan Gable
that'd be nice to be just nice little
feel good get back like a Norman
Rockwell painting yeah have you ever had
a state kind of rally behind I shouldn't
say stay but more just the city of ames
rally behind and you know interact with
you on a show you could say the state of
Iowa I mean let's not make it you know
exclusive let's be inclusive here I mean
I I'm all over Bettendorf I mean Council
Bluffs we're all over the place there we
own oh I can't walk down a street in
Iowa right now yeah I had a lot of other
people ask me on Twitter I mean they
really want you to come to ames and i
definitely want you to come to iowa iowa
state game but they're also asking you
know who would you pick on your
basketball team if you had a you get a
draft would be Harrison Barnes or Doug
McDermott or would you pick Fred Hoiberg
hmm Aaron uh I'll give you the answer on
have to hang up though because we're up
against a commercial break but I look
forward to a follow-up article and make
sure you get that quote right Thank You
Erin Who am I taking i'm gonna go i'm
gonna go Doug McDermott let me go Doug
McDermott there the Dan Patrick show
weekday morning on audience
[Music]